Marvel's newest round of Infinity War toys
have once again revealed perhaps a bit too
much about an upcoming movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
In case you don't remember, Thor: Ragnarok
saw the Odinson lose his right eye in a battle
with his villainous sister Hela, the Goddess
of Death.
While losing an eye barely inconvenienced
the God of Thunder in combat, it did mangle
his look, leaving the hero bruised and battered
and shorn of his locks by the end of Ragnarok,
where Infinity War picks up.
"Who the hell are you guys?"
Hasbro's assortment of Infinity War toys,
as well as Funko's bobbleheads, have made
it perfectly clear that Thor doesn't lose
his eye permanently.
In fact, he seems to get it back in time for
whatever big battle the Avengers have against
Thanos.
But a few toys tell a slightly larger story.
Hasbro's Marvel Legends three-pack gives us
a Thor with an eyepatch, hanging out with
Rocket and a teen-aged Groot - a trio that's
repeated in a LEGO set and Hot Toys' teaser
photos for their own Infinity War action figures.
A later wave of Marvel Legends includes a
second Thor, this time with two working eyes
and a fancy new axe… with a handle made
of Groot.
New Cosbaby figures from Hot Toys also appear
to show the full evolution in Thor's status
quo, fixing a setback the character suffered
in his most recent solo movie.
If they do indeed reflect the events of Infinity
War, the two Thor figures seem to tell a little
story of personal growth and triumph for the
mythical Asgardian fighter.
The first figure shows Thor with an eyepatch,
charging himself up for combat, Dragon Ball
Z style.
He still sports the scars of his battle with
Hela, with only one lightning-charged eye
visible.
All is as expected.
The second figure introduces a two-eyed Thor
with new armor and a new weapon.
Scarring around the figure's right eye is
consistent with the damage Hela caused, with
one big difference: The eyeball is back, suggesting
that the God of Thunder is going to regenerate
his eye as a part of the push against Thanos.
While audiences have seen Thor spontaneously
generate magical armor around his body before,
we've never seen him regrow an actual body
part.
If all this turns out to be true, it begs
the question — why hasn't he re-grown his
hair?
"Life is about growth, it's about change."
Previously, a toy called the Hulk-Out Hulkbuster
seemed to confirm a major moment from the
upcoming superhero movie, revealing that Bruce
Banner will wear one of Tony Stark's Hulkbuster
Iron Man suits before going green inside of
it, bursting out of the armor like a vengeful,
angry nesting doll.
"Wow."
However, it's worth noting that these tie-in
products aren't always on the money, with
occasional liberties being taken with the
story for the sake of making a kickass toy.
Previous reports that a Lego set had revealed
Thor to be using the comic book weapon Jarnbjorn
in Infinity War turned out to be not quite
accurate; it was later confirmed that Thor's
weapon in the movie would be an axe called
Stormbreaker.
So as fun as it is, and as accurate as it
might end up being, it's still worth taking
all of this toy-sourced information with a
healthy abundance of salt.
We'll be able to see for ourselves what happens
to Thor in Avengers: Infinity War when the
movie launches in theaters worldwide on April
27th.
"Ready?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!